right hey what's driving you crazy well
the clock is ticking on the Nevada
Department of transportation's huge drop
a can of project and if you're tired of
hearing hearing about it from me I
hereby gladly hand it over to ndot
spokesman Justin Hopkins
Tropicana is going to involve taking
down part of the Tropicana bridge over
I-15 it's going to include an eight day
closure of Tropicana in both directions
it's also going to include a three-day
full closure of I-15 in both directions
Tropicana Avenue closed for eight
straight days I-15 down below closed for
three straight days so you either want
to avoid this area or you want to plan
ahead learn how to get around all the
traffic restrictions before you set out
the idea Justin so the full closure of
trop is not going to start until after
the night's home game this Saturday
night the full freeway closure is a week
from Saturday we're for sure going to
talk more about that for now the only
upcoming closure still kind of a biggie
we're talking about the exit from the
south 15 to both directions to Trop all
the info you need on ndot's I-15 Drop
app now because this is such a big deal
for traffic we've got other details
ahead coming to the airwaves like better
alternate streets when Tropicana is down
ndot's recommendation for truck drivers
to get around with are expected to be
monster tie-ups when the 15 closes down
buckle up drive carefully please put
down that phone and you can join the
driving crazy conversation it's traffic
eight at eightnewsnow.com